[Music]
nicole kidman is getting oscar buzz for
her performance as lucille ball whoever
did that graphic bravo nice job the
iconic star of the beloved 50 sitcom i
love lucy in the new film which gives us
insight into the real-life marriage
between lucille ball and her husband and
co-star that's desi arnaz it's called
being the ricardos and in some ways
nicole told us this is a double role for
her because she has to transition
between the character lucy played on tv
and the determined entertainment
visionary she was off screen so we spoke
with nicole a couple of days ago from
her home in sydney australia and she
told us about the pressure she felt
taking on the role of such a legendary
comedy icon
okay first we'll just say
congratulations golden globe winner for
the movie we're here to talk to you
about
i would imagine it never gets all
winning awards nicole but congrats to
you congrats
thank you yeah no i actually get sweeter
and sweeter with age you think well
this will never happen again and then it
happens and you're like
but i want to talk about this role in
particular because you know in the
beginning there were people that thought
nicole kidman that's an interesting
choice oh
no no no i can't spend the afternoon
with three women and have to tell the
truth i read that you said it took you
out of your comfort zone how so
oh like way out i wouldn't i was in
extreme discomfort um but at the same
time it was you know it was an
extraordinary challenge and it was just
lovely that aaron sorkin
thought i could do it pregnant women
often vomit i know i could any second
did you have the chatter in your ear
about people who questioned it did that
motivate you to say i will show you or
did you just block out all of that um
tried to just yeah block out all of it
i'm not a
a person that's sort of seeking out all
of the what's online and what what are
people saying and how should i respond
i'm much more about this is a glorious
role and this is a fantastic company of
actors and
get in there and don't don't don't let
the team down as we've heard him do a
hundred times he says
lucy i'm home
what was your approach did you look at
her as two characters or did you think
you know because there's i love lucy as
in lucy ricardo and then there's lucille
ball
yeah i mean initially because there was
the i love lucy show and there was so
much and i didn't know how much was
going to be in the film i thought well i
have to show it with that just down and
then the lucille ball of it was the
discovery
for me because
all of the interviews all of the
documentary footage i had access through
lucianes her daughter
to
secret recordings and
and that's when i discovered the woman
and the woman is
extraordinary she's fascinating and her
life is fascinating and an
inspiration she loves the crowds and the
crowds love her what she sort of came up
against you would
um
fail
pick herself up
keep going and she had this
extraordinary partner but that was a
very complicated relationship
and so all of that is explored in the
film and people will discover her again
and a new generation has access to her
now
when we think of nicole kidman a lot of
us think of red carpet because you are
perfection on the red carpet from your
hair to your heels so i'm wondering how
you prepare for roles like the the scene
with stomping of the grapes
[Music]
because that's a totally different way
of seeing nicole kidman how did you get
ready for something like that
i just put on my sweatpants and a
t-shirt and
put it up on the screen behind me and
literally worked like i can do that
whole grape stomping sequence and do the
whole thing
with the timing and the and i just it
took months i was actually disappointed
that more of it isn't in the film and
then when i got to swim in them because
lucy doesn't do that in the episode she
doesn't swim around in them that was
part of you know she's exploring what's
funny in her head it must have meant
something too that lucy arnez
really embraced you and was is very very
complimentary about your performance
because she said you really captured the
essence of her mother i i would think
that would mean the world to you to hear
it from her yeah it's her mama yes it's
a mama and she's watching her mother in
not just
sort of not not through rose-colored
glasses in the film either so and
watching her father because it's desi
it's called being the ricardo's for a
reason
and it's her parents and so for her to
give
both javier and i the thumbs up
and say
you did it and she doesn't
fake things that's not lucy she's like
her mother
and the way that the movie ended i mean
it was just so touching and so
tender at the same time when you could
just see the marriage was ending
this is my lipstick
keith sat next to lucy when she watched
it and she was and he was like she's
weeping oh
i know wow and i think they couldn't
make it work because of
you know human beings you have deep
flaws sometimes but it doesn't mean that
the relationship wasn't
filled with love these days nicole
kidman is spending time with her love
that's country music superstar keith
urban and their two daughters back in
sydney australia during this pandemic
you all celebrated your 15th anniversary
may i say i love that instagram post
nicole kidman and keith urban please
take us behind the scenes of that
picture keith was i wearing our pajamas
mine was a little more
what does that say about us no no
we're a mix
we're very suited i'm incredibly lucky
to have met him i met him
you know as lucy did as lucy met desi i
met him um
later in life and
it's been the most the best thing that's
ever happened to me
that man is the best thing that's ever
happened to me well i wish you i wish
you well i wish you continued soaring
oscar nominations are coming up
yes can i put it out there
you can put anything out there gal
i'll follow
oh wow she's so sweet and of course
she's so talented and i love the
relation you know i'm a sucker for love
you both know that and i love when a
husband and wife speak so glowingly
about each other that man is the best
thing that ever happened to me yes and
i can say yes for my wife don't you go
anywhere because we're the best thing to
happen to you all right all that matters
this week we'll be right back